mark is with us in Denver a mark welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show what's up so I
am playing on getting engaged in the
next couple months congratulation thank
you very much and my fiancee to be has
$80,000 of student debt I'm wondering if
I should stop all my investing start
spelling as much as I can right now to
get ready for when we say I do well do I
just continue to invest try to build my
wealth on my own and then you know live
my lifestyle as normal until I'm married
no I agree with you out stop everything
and start piling up cash and you know
super super large savings account that
your plan is to write a check out of
that account when you get home from the
honeymoon and let's you know to get a
jump start on that eighty thousand right
what do you make my take home is about
65 days cool what's she make about 35 K
taken after taxes so what's her degree
in for 80 grand my degree first a
nobility okay alright and that's not
that's not been a real sustainable as
far as an income goes interesting all
right well I mean you're gonna have a
not you have a hundred thousand dollar
household income so you're gonna turn
through that eighty very quickly and on
top of that you're gonna get a head
start during the period of engagement by
piling up cash here so yes I would do
all of that and you guys have talked
about this and you're both in agreement
that that this student loan has to be
gotten rid of the Sallie Mae needs her
eviction notice and we don't borrow
money anymore and you've talked about
the money stuff right good very good
cool well congratulations man yes I
would go ahead and prepare for that your
worst-case scenario is that from a
financial perspective is that the whole
thing blows up you don't get married and
therefore you have a pile of cash in
your bank account
oh darn oh darn you know you know you
could probably figure out a way to get
that invested right right now but as
long as the marriage goes through and
the the engagement everything's smooth
and come home from the honeymoon you got
it you know you got thirty thousand
bucks in there to jumpstart on that 80
that sure would be sweet wouldn't it
sure would be yeah that's a good plan
very good plan mark